president putin
recently
you ordered your troops into ukraine
which is a sovereign nation
and this was a mistake
you underestimated the capability
and the fighting spirit of the brave
ukrainian people
and that's understandable
my country
made that same mistake
in vietnam
in iraq
and in afghanistan
these mistakes
led to drawn out conflicts
that depleted our finances
our materials
and cost us much of our most precious
resource of all
american blood
so i remember being a teenager in the
u.s and arguing against the
impeding invasion of iraq and
afghanistan and literally arguing at the
time i was just in school right so
you're arguing with classmates but why
but those are the people if we don't go
get them they're going to destroy our
way of life right that's what we're
taught right and that's what would
justify
the the utter terrorism that we've
unleashed on that world they hate us
they hate us because we're blowing them
up right it's a self-created uh problem
and it's it's it's all about oil it's
about wealth it's about power it's about
hegemony and
you know the us unfortunately doesn't
have a leg to stand on when it comes to
condemning illegal foreign invasion i
think what blew my mind was watching
condoleezza rice speak out against the
invasion look we're all against the the
the
you know illegal invasion you know and
honestly i'll have a lot of respect for
a ukrainian citizen who takes up an
ak-47 and fires shots
at an invading russian soldier just as i
would respect the palestinian who does
the same thing against an israeli
soldier who attacks him and for that i
might be labeled an extremist but for
another i'm labeled as as modern and
articulate and the hypocrisy is they
actually used footage of palestinians
like a palestinian girl resisting
israeli occupation palestinian children
being blown up by the israeli military
they put that as ukrainians resisting
russia they actually use that footage of
palestinians resisting israel and they
mislabeled it as footage of ukrainians
resisting russia and they supported that
the same footage they would have labeled
as terrorist and violence and evil
previously now is being celebrated why
because those that are defending their
homeland look more like the general
population right as as the reporters
themselves have said listen these are
blue-eyed blonde europeans they have
netflix accounts they have instagram
accounts you know they're just like us
i'm sorry it's really emotional for me
because i see european people with blue
eyes and blonde hair being healed
children be killed every day with
putin's missiles
and his helicopters and his rockets so
we have to stand with them
meanwhile it was those same journalists
those same reporters those same elected
officials that were beating the drums of
war against the victims of iraq and
afghanistan that we killed because
frankly what they do is uh they just
don't value brown life as much that
that's what it comes down to
they label muslims and arabs as the
other as the foreigner they otherize
them they dehumanize them they feed us
lies just like putin is feeding his
country lies to justify the illegal
invasion in the massacre and we've
literally killed millions directly or
indirectly in the middle east over the
last 30 years you know we've done
of the greatest global acts of terrorism
and had russia done
what we're doing we condemn them in fact
we are right now we're condemning them
in in ukraine for doing what we've done
in iraq for doing what we've done in
afghanistan so we condemn what's
happening but we also condemn the united
states when it's done the very same
criminal acts of aggression let's let's
not mince words here
the invasion of iraq was criminal was
illegal it led to the deaths of hundreds
of thousands of civilians directly not
to mention indirectly
the invasion of afghanistan was likewise
illegal
the
occupation of the palestinian land and
the israeli crimes against humanity
funded by u.s tax dollars it is illegal
and just as we celebrate the ukrainians
who resist illegal occupation
why don't we celebrate the palestinians
even the iraqis even the abrahamis
who have resisted
illegal invasion especially the afghanis
from empire after empire people are
afraid to say this but i say now is the
time we come out and condemn all
foreign military invasion and occupation
whether it is by russia or whether it's
by the u.s we have to be loyal to
principles and truth
not to politics and flags before this
problem we saw that europe uh was
dealing with a huge influx of refugees
from the middle east again from
conflicts that we created let's be very
clear
daesh
which is created other chaos in the
middle east
would not have existed had it not been
for the illegal invasion of iraq
you know we are directly responsible for
the atrocity when i say we as the
american people for the atrocities
daesh is unleashed in the middle east
and the subsequent refugee problems that
happen either as a result of daesh or
happen as a result of the corrupt
dictatorships that we support over there
that we fund over there so the reality
is we ourselves as the united states of
america with the support of europe have
created the refugee crisis in the middle
east and what we saw when refugees were
literally escaping for their lives
to europe was closed borders was turning
away of ships was thousands and
thousands of refugees drowning to their
death while european nations stood by
so they said we cannot take in refugees
but again now that the refugees are
you know green-eyed uh blue-eyed
blond-haired you know white people
i mean i'm sorry it's very emotional for
me because i see
european people with blue eyes and
blonde hair being healed they're
welcoming them with open arms again it
shows the hypocrisy even how they speak
about them right so when they talk about
european refugees they talk about
families that are victims
when they talk about muslim refugees
they try to label them just as men that
are potential aggressors you know the
rhetoric the language that is used is
very problematic and i think it just
reflects xenophobia that's all it
reflects so this is not getting into the
politics between russia
nor ukraine right
so you're talking about this is just the
blatant
double standards and hypocrisy right
that i mean what what should someone who
is kind of obvious it's something that
now doesn't take much of pointing out
when when you see obviously again the
reporters
like the many reporters who are coming
out you can see people can see that
right now yeah well just to put it
bluntly these are not refugees from
syria these are refugees from
uh neighboring ukraine i mean that
quite frankly is part of it these are
christians they're white they're
um
they're very similar to people many
people who live in poland and this is
not a developing third world nation this
is europe this isn't
a place with all due respect you know
like iraq or afghanistan that has seen
conflict raging for decades you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully talk about the
millions of lives that were killed using
u.s taxpayer dollars talk about the
torture we saw in abu ghraib as you
mentioned in guantanamo which continues
to this day
you know uh the more italian i think is
an excellent film i recommend everybody
to see about one of the experiences of
one of the people which is called the
mauritanian uh is is is
again highly recommend people to watch
it again normally i don't encourage
people to watch films but something like
this is important for people to be
educated about the experience it's it's
a true story about somebody who's
wrongfully locked up in guantanamo the
documentary dirty wars
i've seen it you know everybody's got to
watch that we literally kill people like
we play video games sitting in the
arizona desert
playing with people's lives with these
so-called signature drone strikes
example many have argued they create
more terrorists than they kill the night
raids in afghanistan many have argued
they create more terrorism
i don't disagree with that when you drop
a bomb from a drone you're investing
you're you are going to cause more
damage than you're going to cause good
it isn't just top generals either former
cia counterterrorism chief robert
grenier has admitted that drone strikes
are creating more enemies than we are
removing from the battlefield even some
former drone operators themselves have
pointed out that drone strikes have only
fueled the feelings of hatred that
ignited terrorism and groups like isis
while also serving as a fundamental
recruitment tool similar to guantanamo
bay
that kills civilians mostly and you know
what even the person pulling the trigger
doesn't know who the heck he's killing
because what they're killing is
signatures so if somebody fits a pattern
if they go to a certain location that's
enough to get them killed
it's disgusting we're killing people
without even knowing how all paid for
bios taxes i wonder why they hate us so
again listen we are people of principle
we're people of peace of justice of
equity we believe that you cannot get
close to the creator without love and
sincere service to the creation and on
the day of judgment after monotheism one
of the first things that people will be
questioned about is sacred blood how you
shed the blood of the creation of god it
doesn't matter what the religion is if
you unjustly shed blood
there will be hell to pay for that
and unfortunately in the us we're very
complacent in shedding innocent blood
abroad
and
you know we see the havoc of that when
other governments do so you know we see
the uproar against russia
we should have seen that uproar in the
invasion of iraq and afghanistan and to
be fair we did by some segments of our
fellow americans i mean i remember my
father taking me to dc and we protested
against but it needed to have been
louder
and we see in the end illegal invasion
doesn't work
so this is not about
one religion
versus the other religion or this group
first that group this is about justice
this is about
you know awakening
you know good human beings who are in
these positions like you mentioned to go
ahead and make a difference to yeah
let's live up to our ideals that's all
i'm calling for look i obviously believe
in america that's i choose to be an
american citizen i choose to live here i
think despite
the horrific problems our nation has
it's actually still a bit more just than
many others